the real reason 4/20 has become a STONER
holiday is a little hazy but one thing's
for sure it's blazed its way into
popular culture something fierce
inspiring every nerd with a Bob Marley
poster and a stack of Taco Bell coupons
to call out sick that day on account of
their sore throat so it comes as no
surprise that movie studios record
labels and even game developers would
take advantage of its unofficial
festivities if he a vacant ten minutes
we call it Domino's whether you're a
die-hard gamer or a dedicated music
lover be sure to mark April 20th 2018 on
your calendar because there's a ton of
cool new stuff coming out that day here
are some of the most smokin releases you
can't afford to miss this 4/20 super
troopers to the long gestating sequel to
the 2001 cult comedy super troopers is
finally coming to theaters this year
after a successful indiegogo campaign
made a second outing for everyone's
favorite vermont state troopers possible
written by and starring comedy troupe
Broken Lizard the movie will pick thorny
Foster Mac rabbit and Farva against a
group of Canadian Mounties after a small
slice of Canada is found to actually be
on US soil by the time the film drops it
will have been almost two decades since
the Broken Lizard guys first appeared as
the outrageous law enforcement unit
though it appears that not a lot has
changed for the characters in that time
Broken Lizard founding members Steve
Lemmy told Vermont newspaper 7 days well
we do all have cell phones in this movie
but otherwise it seems like time has
Stood Still for these state troopers
rampage on the surface rampage doesn't
look like your typical 4/20 release but
one glimpse of the trailer and the logic
becomes clear this Dwayne Johnson
blockbuster looks like the product of an
especially smokey brainstorming session
the flick is actually based on a series
of video games in which the player has
to take control of a giant beast and
destroy an entire city before the
military takes you down but this this is
something different the former WWE
superstar has faced off against some
fearsome opponents in his time but this
April we'll get to see how the rock
fares against a genetically modified
30-foot wolf don't expect him to be
wrestling with huge animals however he's
actually on their side sounds like a
typical Tuesday night for everybody's
favorite hard-hitting heavyweight
[Music]
God of War the hotly-anticipated God of
War is finally just around the corner
not only will the latest entry in the
action series see brand new gameplay
elements like an emphasis on exploration
but it will boast a brand new
environment for players to traverse
while previous installments have all
been based around Greek mythology this
time out Kratos and his son at Reyes
will be kicking butt in a world of Norse
myth instead the game's writer and
director Corey Barr log is confident the
fans will dig the new god of war when it
hits shelves on 4/20 on his PlayStation
Blog bar log wrote first let me say this
is my favorite release day of my entire
career if I live to be a hundred I do
not think I will be able to top this
release day Nintendo lavvo the success
of Nintendo's switch cemented the
company's position as the king of party
hardware on 4/20 those parties are going
to get even better with the addition of
cardboard yep you heard that right
cardboard the Nintendo logo is a variety
of different perforated cutout kits that
the user builds at home these toy cons
as Nintendo's calling them are able to
interact with the game software it might
seem like a bizarre concept but
according to Nintendo director Shinya
takahashi
playing with cardboard is quite common
for Japanese kids it's not so
far-fetched if you consider how familiar
the material is at least to Japanese
people who from a young age use it to
play and as a material for creating
things such as fancy crafts whether
Western gamers will warm up to the idea
as anybody's guess as many will likely
be put off by the price tag the variety
kit and the robot kit retail at $69.99
and $79.99 respectively but can you
really put a price on this much fun Back
to the Future manga Hollywood has been
trying and failing to successfully adapt
Japanese properties for Western
audiences for years now but rarely does
the relationship go the other way on
4/20 we're going to get the chance to
see what something truly American looks
like through a Japanese lens and not
just any old lens
Yusuke Murata the illustrator who
adapted popular web comic one punch man
into a full-fledged manga announced his
own Back to the Future project during a
recent promotional event in Tokyo the
film screenwriter Bob Gale is acting as
a supervisor on the project which will
reportedly
expand on the story of Marty McFly with
material not seen in the original
trilogy the first images showed just how
great a job Murat has done at capturing
Marty and the rest of the cast
especially Christopher Lloyd's Doc Brown
thankfully for those of us living
outside Japan Murat says back to the
future which will be titled be TTFN will
be collected and published on 4/20 sting
and Shaggy album when sting appeared at
the Grammys earlier this year those in
attendance were enjoying a performance
of his classic Englishman in New York
and they got a surprise shaggy who
changed the lyrics to Jamaican in New
York and debuted a snippet of the pair's
first single don't make me wait at the
end of the performance be it wasn't me
singer announced that the two were
releasing a joint Caribbean inspired
album on 4/20 according to billboard the
two musicians immediately hit it off
during a fundraiser thanks in part to
their mutual love for Jamaica sting
opened up about their friendship saying
we just had a report in the early 80s I
was in Jamaica a lot I wrote every
breath you take in Jamaica so Jamaica
was a kind of refuge and obviously a
great influence on my own musical DNA
with reggae so I felt I owed a debt to
Jamaica if don't make me wait is any
indication we'd say stings paid off his
debts to Shaggy's Caribbean homeland and
we are all richer for it
new A Perfect Circle album alternative
rock supergroup a perfect circle is back
with a brand new album this April and
it'll be their first major release in 14
years on 4/20 their fourth album eat the
elephant will hit record stores
nationwide a perfect circle founder and
vocalist Maynard James Keenan explained
the decision to release their fourth
studio album on 4/20 telling access the
20th of April is British
singer-songwriter Kareem arounds
birthday she's a dear friend who's
extremely difficult to shop for pressure
off of course I must also note that the
potheads are gonna be thrilled that this
album comes out on 4/20 may it serve as
a glorious soundtrack to accompany all
of the giggling and vexing sounds of
nibbling and snacking
fingers crossed Cheech and Chong will be
proud music munchies and bellowing out
we think the iconic duo would approve
yeah thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]